I need your help. With what? What
do you know about the multiverse.
Welcome back everyone this is my doctor strange
multiverse of madness video for the new doctor
strange variant we're going to see in the movie
who they're calling defender strange there are
a couple variants of doctor strange in the movie
in some connections and easter eggs for the loki
series and the new main version of loki so if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i'll be doing full episode
videos for moon night after the book of boba fett
episodes so there's a lot of really cool stuff
coming up in the next few months but we've all
watched the new doctor strange multiverse
of madness trailer a billion times first as
the spider-man no way home post credit scene then
again after they just released it online and most
of the trailer is setting up doctor strange as
the main villain of the movie not our main doctor
strange although baron mordo is still trying
to kill him in a bunch of the trailer footage
the person marvel wants you to think is the main
villain based on the way they edited the trailer
is doctor strange supreme or evil doctor strange
however you want to think about him from the what
if series they told you during what if that some
of these characters would be showing up in the
live-action marvel movies we knew captain carter
was going to be one of them but i was surprised
when they revealed strange supreme in the trailer
especially because he seemed like he had turned
good at the end of the what-if finale when the
watcher uwatu tasked him with watching over that
pocket dimension where they trapped killmonger
black panther in infinity gauntlet ultron
i guess a lot can happen in a short period
of time but they did release a new synopsis
which sort of confirms what's actually going
on during the film it just reads now that iron
man and captain america have left after a fierce
battle in avengers end game former genius surgeon
and the strongest magician of them all doctor
strange is expected to play an active role as
central figure in the avengers however using his
magic to manipulate time and space at will with
the forbidden spell that is considered the most
dangerous has opened the door to a mysterious
madness called the multiverse to restore a world
where everything is changing strange seeks the
help from his ally wong the sorcerer supreme and
the avengers most powerful scarlet witch wanda
but a terrible threat looms over humanity in
the entire universe that can no longer be undone
by their power alone even more surprising the
greatest threat in the multiverse looks exactly
like doctor strange so they're just trying to hype
up the idea that this strange supreme is going to
be the actual main villain of the film now they
just want you to think that that might be a big
twist where somebody else winds up being a secret
main villain marvel's always very misleading with
the way they pitch you their movies and the way
they cut the trailers but the idea is that during
the trailer baron mordo says the real danger to
reality in the multiverse is you doctor strange
in marvel is meaning that it's doctor strange in
all of his variants like in every reality doctor
strange is one of the greatest threats because
he's so powerful and because he throws caution
to the wind the same way that iron man most of the
other avengers do and speaking of spider-man no
way home connections the same way that spider-man
does like spider-man causes most of the problems
that he has to solve during spider-man no way
home but during the trailer the reason why baron
mordo is attacking the main mcu doctor strange is
because of the two spells that he performed during
spider-man no way home and the way that he messed
with the time stone during avengers infinity war
avengers end game he has that dialogue where
he says your crimes against reality will not go
unpunished that's what he's talking about they
also referenced this during spider-man no way
home when doctor strange is trying to caution
peter saying we changed reality fundamentally
to bring back countless lives and you want me to
do it again because you're having a bad time but
they did it anyway so if baron mordo was mad at
doctor strange for messing with reality during
avengers infinity war in avengers end game what
they did during spider-man no way home made him
even more pissed off at doctor strange like during
the movie they break reality for a hot second but
the second spell really was only kind of like
a soft patch like flex taping the multiverse
that could instantly patch bond seal and repair so
baron mordo's bill that he referenced at the end
of the first doctor strange movie has just come
due he said there's always a cost to messing with
reality on this level and he's taken it on himself
to go full thanos on all the magic users of the
mcu who he thinks are misusing magic perfectly
balancing the magic scales is all things should
be that also includes scarlet witch and what
she's done with the hex during wand division
that would have been enough to land her on baron
mordo's list doctor strange is just at the top of
the list the other new version of doctor strange
that i mentioned defender strange we see spinning
uncontrollably through dimensions it's exactly
the same scene we saw of mcu doctor strange in
the first movie on his fantastic voyage across
the multiverse as far as i can tell there's only
one scene of him in the trailer here but because
they're hyping up doctor strange supreme as the
main villain as evil doctor strange you can assume
that pretty much any other doctor strange variants
that show up in the film if there are more than
three versions of him are probably good characters
defender strange is based on the version of doctor
strange from the classic defenders comic book team
not the marvel netflix defenders with daredevil
luke cage jessica jones and iron fist i'm talking
about the og defenders their team debuted for
the first time in doctor strange number 183 and
the team was doctor strange teaming up with namor
and the hulk to fight the undying ones and their
leader the nameless ones who were kind of like
these lovecraftian beings from another dimension
who ruled over earth thousands of years ago along
with the elder gods but marvel didn't actually
call the team the defenders until their next big
story where they were fighting against the techno
wizard called yandroth valkyrie also became part
of the team that time too the reason why defender
strange has the ponytail like this in addition
to the defender's costume is just to make him
look as visually different from the other doctor
strange variants in the movie as possible so that
casual fans can tell them all apart when they're
fighting on screen when things get really crazy
like that's why they have doctor strange supreme
here looking like he has that magical taint
darkening all of his features so that he looks
more evil and sinister than the other versions
things just got out of hand they did the
exact same thing during the loki series
during episode five when they gave us the
many many loki variants like they're all
loki variants but some of them are so different
that they don't even look like tom hiddleston
why the hell is there an alligator in here like
boastful loki classic loki kid loki all played by
totally different actors and you have alligator
loki superior loki so after seeing all of them
together in a giant battle royale in the loki
series seeing a bunch of doctor strange variants
fighting each other in multiverse of madness
should be easy for everyone also it does seem
like a version of loki from the loki series will
appear during the movie like in this scene with
scarlet witch where you see her light up her
chaos magic here behind her it looks like one
of those portals from the tva with that same type
of energy there were a lot of you that were asking
when reality is breaking during spider-man no way
home because of all these spells where is the tva
why aren't they showing up to stop this because
even after the events of the loki series with
the kang multiverse war erupting in what seems
like the main version of kang taking over the tva
getting rid of he who remains king this version
of the tva would still be very active we might
get a couple hints about what's going on with that
during doctor strange multiverse of madness but i
think they'll save most of that for loki season
2 along with ant-man 3 quantum mania the other
cool thing the spider-man no way home writers
revealed was they actually had to make major
changes to the plot of the movie because marvel
flipped the order that all the movies came out
originally we were supposed to see doctor strange
multi-first submanas before spider-man no way home
so originally what was going to happen with doctor
strange is that he performs this forbidden spell
using the darkhold that's the spell you see
him weaving with the chaos magic in the trailer
it supposedly causes even more trouble for
reality the multiverse than what we saw from
his spell on spider-man no way home then he
scarlet witch sorcerer supreme wong america
chavez would have faced doctor strange supreme to
try and stop him from destroying all of reality
like he almost did during what if then the events
of spider-man no way home would have taken place
after they flex taped the multiverse spider-man
would have come along asking doctor strange to
make everyone forget that mysterio reveals his
identity and originally the major difference
here is that doctor strange would have been
way more against doing the spell the first
time telling peter you have no idea how bad
this could go messing with the multiverse could
cause catastrophic problems for all of reality
because he would have experienced a version of
that already from the darkhold chaos magic spell
in strange supreme but in the original version
the basic plot of spider-man no way home would
have pretty much been the same they still do
the first spell it still goes wrong bringing all
the multiverse characters to the mcu and he was
still going to perform the second spell to make
everyone forget peter parker entirely so changing
the orders that the movies came out only changed
that part of doctor strange's story in no way home
there were a billion other spider-man no way
home deleted scenes for all the characters and
i've done a couple videos about them there were
a couple alternate endings so i'll add links for
all those in the description below but now the
writers said that the way the marvel phase 4
story plays out is that doctor strange knows way
less about the multiverse during no way home and
that's why during the movie he was yelling at
spider-man saying how they know frighteningly
little about the multiverse but performing both
of the spells the way you saw go down in the film
only makes him more curious to explore the
multiverse like curiosity killed the cat like
oh you've wetted my appetite but now i want to
see some more of the multiverse and now that's
why during doctor strange multiverse of madness
he wants to use the dark hole to perform this
forbidden spell quote unquote and that's what
they're referencing in the synopsis for the movie
using his magic to manipulate time and space
with a forbidden spell that is considered the
most dangerous has opened the door to a mysterious
madness called the multiverse and it sounds like
that darkhold spell with the chaos magic is
the reason for the main mcu earth going crazy
like this in the trailer the side effects of the
forbidden spell when he says things just got out
of hand at the end of the trailer i'm wondering
how similar his story in the movie is to the what
if episodes like is he changing reality in service
of some big christine palmer twist because she
seems like a pretty significant plot point in the
movie but hopefully that explains what's going on
with all the doctor strange variants during the
movie if you have any other questions just write
them below in the comments we'll get some more
trailer footage pretty soon while you wait for
everything click here for my brand new morbius
trailer video and andrew garfield easter eggs
and click here for all my spider-man no way home
deleted scenes and all the alternate endings
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!